[Music]
i absolutely love japanese food and it's
something i've always been dying to know
how to make properly so i'm a sushi
version until today i'm going back to
the floor to get the ultimate lesson in
the perfect sushi here we go in the deep
end
i've come to the award-winning aya
restaurant in the west end
the sushi chefs here have trained for up
to 10 years and are all experts
hand-picked from japan
teaching me today is
quinn
overseen by sushi master karasan
hi how are you
good to see you okay i'll be tackling
three sushi classics dragon roll scallop
nagiri and spicy tuna roll
but first it's back to basics rice so
how long would you wash rice for when
you first arrived in a japanese kitchen
for three years minimum three years
three years just washing rice
cauliflower he did rice for six years
was a naughty boy
the rice is washed three times leaving
it soft but sticky enough to mold
and this is the most important thing for
sushi because we say the sushi rice is
the part for sushi yes yeah
i've been fast tracked through years of
rice washing and now it's time to learn
how to make my first dish
a real work of art
the dragon roll avocado eel cucumber and
salmon row intricately wrapped in
seaweed paper called nori and rice but
there's one big catch
you have to do within two minutes they
have to do it within what within two
minutes in two minutes but it's
impossible to have two minutes
i've been told to copy karasana's every
move
it's an amazing way of fanning out an
avocado jesus christ huh everything's so
precise everything's so
it's almost like it's in military
fashion
next step for karasun the eel but i'm
still struggling with the basics
the rice sticks to your hands so quickly
yes
karistan's almost finished
he's so precise
this is for one portion one person yeah
i'm uh i'm just i'm feeling slightly
nervous because i
i feel for the first time in my cooking
career after 21 years in the kitchen i'm
at my depth jesus christ in under two
minutes karasand's done and i've only
just begun
it's incredible
the level of concentration oh [ __ ]
amount of work that goes into it
so underestimated
13 minutes later dragon roll eventually
done
oh my worries the timing 30 minutes in
two minutes